こんにちははじめ社長です4億円の家に
隠れたドラゴンボールを7個探せる
の昔やった企画のサリオはいというわけで
皆さんはドラゴンボールというものをご
存知でしょうかえ1つ星から7つ星合計7
個のドラゴンボールがあるんですけれども
全部集めると願いが何でも叶い
ます是非とも欲しいそんなドラゴンボール
ていうやばい白物なんですけれども
ドラゴンボールの中だと7個のドラゴン
ボールが世界中に飛び散っててそれを
見つけるっていうのがまあ大まかな
ストーリーなんですよそんなね7つ見つけ
たら願いが叶うドラゴンボールなんです
けれどもなんと
今4億円のお家に7個飛び散ったらしい
です昔住んでた家でもドラゴンボール7個
探したことあるんですけれども4億円の家
めちゃくちゃでかいから難易度めっちゃ
高いんじゃないかなと思いつつま僕もね
もうこの家に住み始めて結構月日が経っ
てるのでどこに隠されも見つけられる自は
ありますちなみに俺マジでドラゴンボール
がどこに隠されてるか知りませんなので
マジで実写版ドラゴンボール本当にどこに
あるか分からないんですけども4億円のお
家にあるドラゴンボール7個見つけてみ
たいと思いますいや主しよなめんで送ん
なし必ず見つけて俺の願い世界破滅を叶え
[音楽]
ますはいというわけで早速探していき
ましょうこれどういうルールなんですか
なんか大地っていう論が
ああダイロねダロンがそのダイロンがまず
星の数が上がるごとに難しいようにオール
置いてありますなるほどじゃ星1個は結構
レベル1みたいなあそうですじゃ星7が
マックスってことねああ分かりやすいら
そんなの簡単だっぺ
やどこの方言あと1時間なんかフリーザが
攻め込んでくるらしくてここにマジか
フリーザ4の攻め込んでてきちゃう制限
時間は1時間ってことですね分かったおら
絶対見つける行きましょうでは1時間よい
スタート行き
ます
いやあ前住んでたちとは比べ物にならない
からなサイズ感
がらワクワクする
ぞ舐め
てるおいブルマンおめえこれなめてん
ぞぬいぐるみとぬぐのに早速1つけたぞこ
ブルマこれ簡単すぎるぞえこんな感じでも
いいのまレベル1はその程度だよって話
ですねまそうだよねめっちゃ綺麗見て
めっちゃ綺麗ですよいやでもまレベル1は
さすがにこのオープニングラッキーみたい
な感じですねこちら一神中ですやっぱ1で
一番簡単のやつということなので
ちっちゃいめぐみちゃんとダークネスの間
に置いて
もらいますじゃあ2個目探す
かいやここから
はレベル2もそんな難しいとこないんじゃ
ない
[音楽]
のうん一応ここにあの管理人シロと繋が
れるドラゴンレーダー持ってる本当に
弱かったらヒトもらっていいかどうぞそれ
は
でかいだからなるく見つけてんなここは
精神と時の部屋か失礼する
ぞそんな時間はないそんな時間はねえか
ほら修行がしてえ
ぞ本当にマジで見つけよこういうとこに
あるんじゃねえの
かさすがに安易かだがオの周りの仲間は
バカしかい
ねえあいつらの隠すとこなんで手に取る
ように分かる
ぞ1時間で見切れるかどうかだなない気が
するなここ
はあこういう中とかあさすがにないかこう
いうカメラの帽子つことかにしばせて
るっていう可能性も
[音楽]
あるない
なあない
なないな痛ですここはないロッカーとか
ありそうだよなこんだけ数があれ
ばそこかにおい全部しまっとるよねレベル
2ぐらい
はさらっと見つけ
てうわないかこういうとことかありそうだ
よね本当にありそうヘルメットの中と
かいやドラゴンボールのサイズ的に靴に
入るか入らないかみたい
な誰の靴誰の靴これえ女もっぽくない
なんかえ誰の靴これオラが釣るこんな女に
この靴入ったやついねえ
ぞ靴置いてくてこなくない普通え誰かか
やつか
なここはない
なこっち行く
ぞこういうところと
[音楽]
かないない
ないさすがにないよねでもほらどうやって
見んだこれ武術使えねえぞらいやこれやめ
ときましょう大丈夫大丈夫ここない10分
経ちました早え
なもう10分1個しか見つかってねえ
ぞいやこんなとことか行くかなここはあの
掃除用具入れる
場所
いやあ一応隠したメントが
Youtuberだからそんななんか
しょうもないとこに隠さないと思うんだで
ももしここだったらだよ
ね
ないない
ない
ねえここはねえぞブルマン可能性あるなら
ここだよね地下とか
にいや今地下潜ると時間かかるから
見つかんなかったら地下行きます今じゃ
ねえいやちょっといやそんなバカなやつが
おるかこれはストックルーム今まで動画を
で使ったものを置けましょうここも多分
最後ら辺だね探してると時間がもったい
ねえまずはしっかりえなんだっけ中身中と
なんだっけ三神王を探しに行くぞ三身王
って野球1回に一つぶしがあったってこと
は多分同じフロアにはねえ2階にあるはず
[音楽]
だここがレトリーボングの本拠地だああ
はいはいはいはいはい
はいはいこういうとこ
ねない
か
広い広いぞ
これ何これ
くそおいねえぞ広すぎだぞ定綺麗
ないやこんなとこにしまう
かない
ぞ
[音楽]
いやあない
なあ溶けたこおりのなか
に
いやこれねえ
なやないないないこないすないないない
ここは
ええ初めてあけたけど俺これ
今こんな安なところには隠さないっていう
か例えばだけどこういう中と
[音楽]
か
ブルマンけたぞ2つ星見つけましたよこれ
でドラゴンボールが2つ揃ったあと5つだ
中担当まですやっぱドラゴンボールは赤い
場所にもあると思うで僕はそののウセット
し
[音楽]
ます住んでるわけねレベル的にはてことは
多分もうこのフロアは1回後で見よう3系
だ1系2個2系に1個こ順に来れば3系に
もあるん
だこういうなんかアな
さあるある
ある誰か後で片付けといて
くださいくそねえかクラ
ボックス溶けた氷のな
にあないいや多分三つ星具合までは見つけ
られると思うんだ自力でこういうところと
[音楽]
かねえ
かないねこういう隙間とかありそうじゃ
ないマジでこういう隙間とかちょまだ難度
のレベルがわかんないね1と2だけだとえ
本
[音楽]
どここれ1個隠したっすよも星な4見つけ
られそうここ
にいいのかブルマそんなヒントもらって
特別にいやてて
な言ってる間にも20分経ってますやばい
おらこいつ結婚すんぞ本当に怒られ本当に
やめましょう本当にそろそろごくごく
終わっていいマジで探しに行く
かナバが隠した場所
だろさすがに思思考
考えろここにドラゴンボール
が待ほふざけてるまじ見つかんないから
ゴミ箱と
か
ねねえなええ4でしょ4です中の上ぐらい
の難易度ってことでしょそそううっすねえ
どこだこのサイズ感でしょいやねえな
さっき見たよね
ここえないないないない
ないないぞないぞブルマもう1頻度くれ
ねえ
かこっからこっちですこっちよりこっち側
ってことはいこっち側ねありがてえブルマ
てていやこん中とかじゃない
[音楽]
のいやこのサイズには置けない
はず
ええ
あ
やい
えいやいやいやないないないないない本当
にないほら分かったかもしん
[音楽]
ねそんな安易じゃないかいまずでわから
んいやそんなに入れれねえ
よここも見たしょ
[音楽]
えバコーンで外したら出てくると
かいやなんかダメなこ外しちゃダメな感じ
[音楽]
すごいマジでやばいとこって外してるた俺
これあああった
えおいブルマおめえバカかや
ゲットえぐいわどうも通神中担当のけす
ですえっと3階の畑の撮影部屋のエコンの
とこら
[音楽]
辺
どこ行っ
た4とこのレベルでしょう567どうなん
のこれとりあえず3つ見つかりました残り
時間何分残り時間30分ですあと半分かま
ちょっと星3とかすぐ見つけたいよら4
行って
くる結構難しいぞこれ俺ワクワクしねえ
ぞ4回に来ました
ねえ
[音楽]
なやべえやべえこの部屋も全然可能性があ
るってことは
ブルマシロにヒントもらえねんかもらい
ましょうもしもしおすら悟空お悟空おめえ
デチかデチだデチドラゴンボールが
見つかんねえ
ぞちょっとだけヒントくれねえかどの
ドラゴンボールが見つかんねえんだなんか
地味に見つかってるんだけど4階にあるか
どうかだけ聞きてえなてかなんならどの
フロアにどのドラゴンボールあるか教えて
くれ1階にだな2個ある
な個階個あるな2系に2個3階に1個あん
な3系に1個4系には何個あんだ4系には
1個あんな4系に1個かちなみに4系の
ドラゴンボールの星の数聞いていいか星7
だパスありがとなカセにのちゃんまたなあ
またなでかいでかいオオオ4回2個ある
けど星7でしょう1番難しい時間がかかる
のでここが
ペス
これペイするぞ1階と2階に1個ずつまた
取り逃しがあるのでそれ探しに行きます
ブルマらちょっとこの洗衣装疲れたぞ
あっち1回着替えます1けちょっと着替え
てきていいか部屋に着替えてくるぞ着替え
ましたレチからつま2階に3つあるわって
言ってまし
たあいつ嘘ついたのかせね6個しかねえと
思ったぞおらじゃあちょっと戦闘衣装
あっちから着替えてくる待ってろ
待たせた
な部やばこれがオラの日
だピッコロのマねっこ
だあの1個行っていいさっきより
熱いこの肩のこれ何kgあると思う何kg
すかそれ
100kgとりあえず今3つ見つかりまし
た1つ星と2つ星と4つ星か星3ぐらいは
見つけたいなねさっきの線路の話によると
この風呂にもう1個それまず
[音楽]
見つけようない俺だったらこの中隠してた
な1
個
えあ
あうわなるほどねこれマジでわかんなく
ないどうやって入れたのそもそもやいいや
いやなるほどねこの金色の正面に入れて
おくと色が分かりづらいってやつか三つ星
ゲットよしいいぞ結構揃ってきたぞ三振中
たと洋平先生ですこの黄色に本来輝いてる
インテリアの中
に入れて隠したいと思い
ます色が似てるんだ
ねこういうことですね
これで今4つ揃ったぜ
あとトップ3か567かで2階にあと2つ
あるんだよね4回一応難しいからちょっと
ここから2階に絞って
探そうでかいぞこれ
は残り20分です
マジかこっからレベルめっちゃ高いって
ことでしょ56がここってことだもんね
そうすねままずはこう
いう裏とかだよね見るべきはいやここに隠
してたら結構キモいけど
ねあ本当になんかやばいことした気がする
今ねなんか
今こういう上のさこういう回路のなんか
隙間とかにあったりしないか
なあやないない気がする
なさすがにねえか
ねえ
かレベル高いでしょそんな簡単なところに
引き出し上げて見つかるとかそんな場所に
ないと思うんだよ
な視点を変えてみるのも大事だ
なないななんかさそこの上とかありそうだ
と思ったんだよね分かるああはいはい銀の
殺しの上とかそういう感じではなさそうだ
な
えいやそんなことするか
なやりかねんよねでもレベル的に
は絶てドラゴンボールよりむずいよアニメ
の
いやあさすがにない
か
うんさすがにないと思いたいないよねない
よねこうわ雲のすないこの風呂に2個
でしょそもそもこのでかい部屋にあるか
どうかも分かんないんだよまだあああああ
ああ忘れてたこ邪魔だな
もこれで行くぜこっちだ多分こういう
ところないちょっと待って本当にやばい
どうしようどうしよう
[音楽]
ええむすん
よさっきも言ったと思うけどこのさ広い
部屋だけじゃないわけじゃんきっと他の
ところも
見よう
[音楽]
えないけども本当に残り10分
ですちょっと最後あのシロにヒントだけ
もらっていいですかはいエグむずいぞ
これおっせら悟空おっと元気がない残り
10分切ってしまったんだが星5星6星7
が見つからない分かりやすいヒントをくれ
ないか星5は料理をする時何をつける煙が
出る時換気戦か分かったかもしれねえな星
6は暑い時には何を
食べるあれ俺さっきでも溶けた氷の中にと
言ながら冷凍触ってたけどな星7のヒント
もくれないか体のお料理をする場所
キッチン周りかありがとよ助かった行って
くる時間ない時間ない時間
ないうわなんかさ前もさこんな場所にあっ
た気がするんだ
けどうわなんか粉降ってき
[音楽]
たすうわこれ開けれたんの
ね白い粉めっちゃ降ってくる誰かこれ
やばい薬隠し
てるどこだ未だに見つけらんない
よえないないないここじゃないのかな換で
もこうやって煙出たらこっち側
かおい同じの
ある絶対こっちだだって誰か仕掛けてたら
こな落ちてこない
もん絶対こっちだ確信持ってわかる絶対
ここにある
ああ割れたら願いかわくなっちゃう
けどびっくりしありまし
た星5よしよしよしよしウ神中担当の
トゥイです僕はですね2階のこのキッチン
のところの換扇の上に置きたいと思います
ここなんて開けたことないですよ僕
おいしょ
うわーねここにね実スペースがあるんで
ここにこう置い
て
セットオッケーですここをね開けたら落ち
てきます
あと2つですよしよしよしよし氷がどこ
行ってたなやっぱここなの
か俺が使い方知らないだけでどっかにある
のか残り5分です
マジ急げ急げいやすごいげてない氷の量
ないか
ないやないないないこの中には
ないないよねないないないないええ氷の中
じゃない
のねえ俺さっき見てたよねでも溶けた氷の
中にて歌い
ながら溶けた氷りの中にあっ
たいやいやどどどうやったんこれ溶けた氷
の中にあったけどマジで凍ってんじゃん
溶けた氷の中やんけどとり見つけました
多分これ星だね竜神中担当大事です僕ここ
の家の管理なのでそこそこ難くしようと
思ってて思いついたのが冷凍庫こん中に
入れ
て水入れて凍らせようかな
[音楽]
[拍手]
とよし
よし
よしおいしくならでもえもえあと1個
やばいあと4分ぐらいも3分ぐらいまずい
よし6個見つきましたあと1
個きつい
けキッチン周りだなこの中のどっかにある
はずだ
[音楽]
あと2分ですやばい本当
やばいこれ7個目のドラゴンボール隠した
もサです終わったわ終わっ
た絶対見つかんないとこにやつやるもん
いや落ち着き絶対どこが寝るはず
だえ
どこ
えこんな飽き方するのこれ
何これ知らないそ出てきたんだけど残り1
分ですまずい
まずいこれ開かないん
だ違うかえマジでどこ
だ絶対新品だねこれはえ
どこやばいやばい本当に分から本当に
分から
残り30秒です
無理あやばいこと起きてる30秒前
やばい落ち
てるどこどこ
どここれじゃないんかな
[音楽]
10987654321
くっそ1個もつらなかっ
[音楽]
たもしもしもしもしさん7個目が見つかり
ませんでした
あららららこれもうちょいヒントもらって
いいですかちょっと探してみたいのよね4
階のキッチンの棚とかでは
ないどういうことお掃除が必要な場所お
掃除が必要な
[音楽]
場所
[拍手]
[音楽]
あのバカたれがありまし
た原作者に怒ら
[音楽]
れろ
あいつやったなマジ
[音楽]
で一応全部揃いましたはいというわけで
ドラゴンボール7個集まりまし
たいややっぱ綺麗だね待ってこれどうした
の結構凝って作ってるけどねこれ
出てき
たよしこれでようやく全部揃いまし
た
[音楽]
よしじゃあ願いかえていいですかお願いし
ますけの眉毛の長さを5cm太してくれ